so you have to understand crypto is
extremely tribal two things happened the
first thing is they thought that I was
manipulating the market they said that I
was fuding the market by layer saying
she's selling and she's out everybody
else is going to copy and start selling
I'm going to FUD the market I didn't
think I was that influential but if they
think I am I'll take the compliment but
the second point and I think this is
more to the point is that people are
extremely emotional they're very tribal
and I actually had a comment somebody
said you're not one of us and I thought
to myself I don't want to be one of you
you're probably broken your mother's
basement I want to be out here in Miami
sending M to my parents building a life
for myself building great savings for so
that I can provide a beautiful life for
my children one day I don't want to be
one of you I'm an independent thinker
you should aim for profit you should aim
for life-changing gains and like I said
you can get back in at any point I don't
have a collectivist mindset